we're now going to look
at the topic of fitting univariate
functions and that means basically
n equals 1. so the so-called feature
vectors or
independent variables x is just a scalar
now what that means is we can actually
do a scatter plot of the data so for
example
uh i could just i could just this is x
this is y
and my data might look like just a bunch
of points like that
okay so i can i can i can plot them like
that
um and that's a scatter plot um
now when i create a model function
y hat equals f hat it's a function and i
can evaluate that for every value of x
so i can plot a curve
right i mean so it might look like this
there that would be my
uh this would be f hat and so
we'll be able in this in this case where
the dimension of x
is one so n equals one your eyeball can
actually judge how well we do of course
we'll also check things like the rms
error and things like that but your
eyeball should be able to take a look at
it and say we're doing a pretty good fit
here
okay so uh beyond the constant fit which
we saw
last time we're going to look at what is
uh you know maybe the
the simplest fit after that um it's
gonna have
two coefficients so p is two and
the first uh the first basis function is
one once again it's the constant
function one
and the second one is just x like that
and so what that says
is that your model has this form uh it's
f hat of x
equals theta one plus theta two x uh so
that is um that's that's the model uh
and of course what we have to guess
is or choose our theta one and theta two
now in this case it's it's like the
previous one with the constant model
it's very
you know we can actually write out what
a is a is this now let's remember what
these
are the rows here represent
uh different data points in my data set
then the first column tells you to
evaluate
your your first basis function at those
points but
you know what that's always one so
that's why you see all the ones here
okay and in the second one i simply just
take x and i just replace it here so
that's x1 x2 x3 and so on
now you know that's an n by two matrix i
can form a transpose a
and invert it and i don't need to use
some fancy numerical thing i mean
i'll say a little bit about the minute i
wouldn't hurt me if i did but
the point is there the two by two matrix
is you know that's
that's something we can actually work
out the inverse of you know it that's
one of those things you're just supposed
to memorize like the quadratic formula
and so you can actually work out what
theta
hat is and it turns out that you can
write the predictor in a in a very
specific way that's actually highly
interpretable
um yeah and i should add you don't have
to do this this is just for
interpretation uh
the truth is there would be absolutely
nothing wrong with the following
code if you were gonna do this is first
build that matrix
step one step two uh you write theta
hat equals this matrix now i'm writing
code
now first i'll write it in non-code a's
pseudo inverse
times uh and here y y d
i think is what we call it right that's
the data the vector of of
data outcomes okay now in code
you would maybe depending on the system
you're using it would look like
that would be a be some kind of uh
backslash right
right in in other ones there would be
some least squares method you would find
or something like that and
you would call that that special
function okay
so um there's absolutely nothing wrong
with doing this
so working it out and having a so-called
analytical formula for it
is just for interpretation it is it
offers
absolutely zero uh you know
advantage in any other way right it's
just for interpretation
computationally certainly this is just
as good as anything else
okay now it turns out it looks like it's
super interpretable which is cool
it says we are going to predict the
following
um well let's let's take a look at it um
so first over here it's going to say
take
x and divide by the average uh and and
sorry subtract the average of x from it
oh and by the way
look at this you actually are going to
divide by the standard deviation
and if you see the part that i have
boxed here it's it's the
it's the it is the um independent
variable x minus its average divided by
its standard
that's super interesting that's a
z-score right so that's a
this is a number and it kind of
typically is between minus one and plus
that's what it is and it's highly
interpretable right so if it's plus
0.5 it means that you are about 0.5
standard deviations above the mean
that's what it means okay and then it
says you're going to multiply that by
the standard deviation of y
rho is the correlation coefficient
between x and y
and then to this thing this is the part
that depends on
x and then to that you have a constant
the average of y
and so it's super interesting if x and y
are uncorrelated
then rho is zero and this whole second
term this just goes away
and it says it says here's your best
straight line fit
the constant model in other words you
just take theta two equal to zero
okay and and you know that makes perfect
sense if two things are uncorrelated
it says that when one is high you are
you have no right to make any claim
about what the other one is doing
and that's exactly what it says you
might as well just guess a constant um
if the correlation is high like rho is
near one
it basically says that whenever this is
positive uh so should be your
your prediction should be above your app
your your uh your average value
so this is the idea it's actually uh
it i mean it's just a nice formula to
interpret but as i said computationally
it offers no advantage of any kind okay
that gives it oh and this is called the
straight line fit
because the graph of that is a line
that's an affine function of course
right so and some people would say
it's a linear this is a linear fit or
something like that and as we know
that's not a linear function and so on
so that's wrong but whatever
just give them a break i suppose you
could say something actually you could
say
in the right social circumstances you
would say something like a just
just for the record that function is not
linear it's affine but it's cool if you
want to call it linear keep going but i
know what you're saying
okay so um and that's i think why this
is called the straight line fit because
the graph is a line or it's an affine
function
okay so here's an example this is one
that should basically kind of be burned
into your mind uh
whenever someone says least squares data
fitting this is the picture you want to
see
and so here's x uh which is a scalar
remember so we're only looking at one
feature
and here's why now and uh they're a
little bit faint but you can see the
little green dots those are our data
points
i don't know how many i have doesn't
matter 50 or something
and the blue line is uh the
uh the so-called straight line fit right
and now what's being minimized is the
each of these points has a height
or a depth above or below this plot
right so these are
what i'm drawing with my pen right now
these are the residuals
right because the that's the data point
and then from that you subtract the
value of the model for that point but
the value of the model is
is the height of the line that because
that's what i'm drawing is f hat
so what this line does is it minimizes
the sum
of the squares of the well of the little
vertical lines that i've drawn and the
the length of the little vertical lines
is the magnitude of the residual
so that that makes perfect uh sense
um and even actually just this is is
quite useful in a bunch of applications
um so here's one it's actually a
very important part of like all the
finance and it goes like this
in that context x here which is a scalar
is the return of the whole market let's
say daily
okay so you know it's either it's plus
.01 means it went up one percent it's
minus .02 went down two percent
that's what it is um and then why is the
return of a particular
asset right like so for example uh
for every day i would get how the i mean
it doesn't really matter the russell
2000 or whatever it is
did that go up or down a percent or
whatever it is and then i could find out
well how did apple do
or google and that would be why right
and i would get
a whole bunch well every day i'd get a
pair x and y
so um those would be the return of the
market and the return of let's just say
apple
okay so now what we're going to do now
is make a straight line fit that
essentially
predicts the return of apple uh
the return of the market and that's
usually written
in it's an affine function of course but
it's usually written in a specific way
and i'll show you what that is it's y
hat that's our prediction of the return
of apple is equal to the following
it's equal to it's an affine function
and it's written several ways so one is
this it's it's
it's written as a risk-free rate
plus alpha now risk-free is something
like you know us
treasuries it's supposed to be uh a
risk-free
way to it's the risk-free interest rate
right so it would be the daily one
that's extremely well approximated by
zero right now but okay
so that's that's the risk-re-interest
rate plus alpha and that's
that's instead of using theta one they
use the parameters alpha and beta plus
alpha
and then plus beta times now x minus mu
market
new market is the mar is the mean market
return
okay by the way for daily stuff that's
just about zero
it is true that the market goes up you
know whatever 15 per year
but if you divide that by 250 you'll
find out that that's a pretty small
uh that the amount it goes up each day
the mean is is relatively small but
anyway that's the new market and so so
if that is positive it means that the
market went up more than its average
that day
if it's negative it means it it went
down or not as much as its
average then beta is what multiplies
that to form the prediction
right so um okay so
uh these are these are referred to as
literally like in this case it's apple
you would say this is f
alphas alph i'm sorry apple's alpha and
apple's
beta and by the way i should say that
that
there's not people use some slightly
different formulas they
divide by you know i don't know they
normalize things
so they're slightly different
definitions of these um
but but always the rough idea is the
same
oh i should also say that some hardcore
economists would argue that alpha is
zero
um that there there can't be any any
return uh you know that that alpha has
to be zero and they would
argue that if that wasn't the case you
know there'd be arbitrage and blah blah
blah
long complicated arguments um i can
guarantee you that
many many people working in hedge funds
will tell you that is false
empirically their alpha is not zero okay
so um so this is so widely known that
people just refer to the uh well maybe
not the alpha because some people even
dispute its existence but certainly the
beta everyone agrees on
um and you just say hey what's the beta
of apple with
the market i don't know what it is right
but the betas range from about you know
point
i mean 0.3 to 1.5 i don't know something
like that right but this is a rough idea
and it's actually uh so people just say
that they would say oh yeah well that's
a
you know that's the beta with the market
or something like that so
okay so and this is nothing but a
straight-line fit the only thing you're
doing is you're making an
affine model or straight-line fit to
predict the
return of a particular uh
um you're predicting it from the return
of the whole market
right so that's that's the idea right so
if beta is one
you know basically says if the market's
up one percent you'd kind of expect
you would expect your uh your asset to
go about one percent too
okay um another use of this
is in uh time series um so here
uh actually what we do is x i is like a
time stamp
and for simplicity we're just going to
take x i equals i and that means that
basically
you have sampled a value y
um at equal and equal times they don't
really have to be equal right for
example in
trading and stuff like that it would be
on trading days and trade
you know so so it would go like you know
monday tuesday friday and then it go
jumps to monday again so it's not actual
equal time
in some cases it is equal time right if
you're
if it's something like you're looking at
the temperature or rainfall
or humidity or something like that there
where there's no weekend
well there's a weekend but it's not
relevant um then
you would uh these would be evenly
evenly sampled
okay and so uh when you form a model
um a straight line model for a for a
case where x represents
time and and in fact in this case we're
just going to make it i
right which literally means the number
of periods that's called the trend
line um it's very cool and then oh if
you subtract the trend line
that is called the de-trended time
series right so it makes
all this makes perfect sense right so
um and theta two you would say is the
trend coefficient
and it's liter it is literally it tells
you
that this increases i mean if theta two
is positive it tells you the
the approximate increase in y when you
go from
you know y i to y i plus one which is
kind of cool right so that that
and all highly interpretable okay so
let's look at an example
um so on the left what you see is if you
look at the data those are those little
green circles they're
hard to see here but you can look at the
book or something like that or
you're not that hard to see that's the
data and the blue line
is the trend line it's nothing but an
affine model it's absolutely nothing
more
and you can see kind of cool stuff you
can see that for example
uh well there's some weird oscillations
in here but
you know kind of more or less looks like
the trend line
um in fact you can see some interesting
things this is petroleum
this is world petroleum consumption and
you can see things like look it's a
little bit below the trend line in 2008
because there was a huge financial
crisis right just as an example
um and i'm not sure what some of the
others uh
but i'm sure someone who knows about
this stuff could could tell you
could tell you stories about why it's
above or below that's the trend line
now what you can do then is you subtract
oh by the way so all sorts of
interesting things the slope of that
trendline
in this case has a beautiful
interpretation it is literally it's our
prediction
of the number the increase in
the number of millions of barrels per
day
uh that are used when you when you move
forward one per year that's how much
consumption is increasing uh okay now if
i subtract the blue line
from the from the green data i get this
and we've done that but we've also drawn
uh we've drawn lines in between things
to just just to
make it easier on the eye just so you
can see it and you get something really
cool that
looks like this now um
it's very cool it shows you in which
year how close were you to the trend
line right so in
in like these years you were pretty
close right it was like
pretty close to the trend line um here
you were below
uh here you're above i i don't know why
but there
is probably some reason for that uh so
that's it and
and here you can see other stuff like
there's some weird cyclical stuff and i
don't know somebody might mumble
something about a business cycle or
something
i i don't know i'm just making that up
um so um
but so this is very very common as you
would see so-called so when someone
tells you
oh you know here's the data and here it
is de-trended
what mean it means that they fit a
straight-line model and they subtracted
the straight-line model
and so what you get are the fluctuations
around the
line model so and this can reveal
interesting stuff and
it's a whole lot easier to understand i
think this plot
than well this one is a good one to see
first because it says basically to first
order
it's increasing linearly it's a pretty
good fit and what this shows
is the the kind of the deviations from
that and tells you
it reveals other structures like when is
it above when is it below and so on
okay um well
if you can do a straight line fit you
know the next obvious thing is to move
to
polynomials uh or something like that
but we'll we'll see there's lots of uh
yep you have lots of flexibility how you
choose your your uh basis functions
so here we're going to take f i of x is
x to the i minus 1 for i equals 1 to p
so that means that f 1 of x is equal to
x to the 0
which is 1. that's our our friend the
offset in the model
f 2 of x is going to equal x to the 1
which is just x
you know f 3 of x is going to be x
squared okay and so on now when i form
a linear combination of these functions
with coefficients given by theta i those
are my or parameters or coefficients
i get a polynomial of x right so here
f hat is exactly this it's theta one
plus theta two x plus
up to theta p x to the p minus one right
because
i'm taking i'm taking p to be the
dimension
of the number of basis functions i have
okay
so it's just a polynomial and in this
case that matrix a
which remember what it is the rows uh
tell you about the different data points
and the columns tell you about the
different features right so
for example the first column tells you
about this first feature sorry this
first
uh basis function the first basis
function is just one and that's why you
see all these ones
the next one is just x1 x2 and so on
that's because of this guy
here and the next one would be the
squares of them and so on so
this matrix comes up a bunch of times
it's called a van der monde matrix i
think we've seen it before
you don't have to know the name doesn't
matter it just happens to have a name
it's named after a mathematician van der
waan
and we've seen it before in for example
polynomial interpolation so it's not
surprising
um okay and so the idea is if i put
theta here and i multiply it by a times
theta
what i'm going to get is actually a
polynomial evaluated at the points
x1 down to xn okay so
so and then we just use you know as
usual
the it's gonna look like this if you're
gonna write code for this
uh it would start like this the first
thing you do is you write a little code
snippet that it that
forms the matrix a okay so you
you'd form this matrix and you could
depending on your language you could do
it all sorts of clever ways
and the truth is in some languages you'd
have some function called vandermonde
and you you'd uh it would literally form
a vandermonde matrix
for you um with the values you'd have to
give it the values x1
down to xn and then it would simply form
a vanderbot matrix but
again not relevant you just you form the
matrix that's a little snippet of code
and then you simply do this and now i'm
writing code i'm not writing math right
now i'd write theta hat
equals a backslash and then it's going
to be
yd which is our vector of of uh
outcomes right so so that's what my code
is going to look like in fact that's
what your code is going to look like
when you do this and you will be doing
this
is there'll be literally that's the
template the template is a section on
top
that says form the matrix a which
literally says evaluate fi at xj you
know
and so on i said that the other way
wrong it's
actually evaluate uh at f
j at x i sorry okay um
and then the then it's kind of a letdown
at the end that's that's the actual line
that does the actual fitting
um and uh and then you might do things
like plot the results or try to figure
out or look at the rms error or things
like that
okay so let's look at an example um so
here i just we have uh
200 points um they are the green dots
here
and you can see it's not like they're
completely random all over the place
you know they're kind of high here a bit
low here and so on
and so here is uh the
the best quadratic fit that corresponds
to p equals three
i have three coefficients i have theta 1
which is the constant theta 2
is the linear term and theta 3 is the
quadratic term and so here you can see
this this thing kind of
curves down so theta 3 is negative in
this case
right that's that's our interpretation
of this
um now here's a fit of degree six
and that means i have p equals seven i
have seven coefficients
and if you look closely at it you'll see
that is
it's it's actually capturing some real
nuance in the data
for example it's kind of going up
rapidly has a little weird bend there
goes down rapidly it kind of comes up
here and so you know it's doing pretty
well
and here it is degree 10 i mean here
we're
really hugging uh the data uh
pretty closely in some cases and here it
is at degree 15
and it's um now it's catching all sorts
of weird stuff
in in the data okay so um
so this is just a picture to show you
what it looks like you can do this this
is like five ten lines of code you could
do this yourself
and you'll get results like this uh
by the way um what this brings up
immediately is the question
is what degree model should i use
okay and we're going to answer that uh
in maybe the next uh in the next section
or
uh or soon we're going to answer answer
that question the the
uh answer that question is not totally
obvious right because
if you simply wanted to do the best you
could on fitting your your data that
you've got
you should use as big a degree as you
can
handle we'll see what the the problem
with that is
uh soon but that's later
the final topic uh in this section is is
the idea of
we've already seen regression and then
this is so-called linear in the
parameters data fitting by least squares
and they're very closely related in fact
the truth is they're really kind of the
same thing
um with two different notation
conventions
i'm using mostly the the conventional
notation
although i think my statistician friends
still cringe when they see some of the
things i write down they don't like me
writing the matrix a
for example for the coefficient matrix
but whatever
it's it's pretty close but what i want
to do now is just
elucidate what the difference is between
a regression model and one of these
linear in the parameters model
um the fact is they're just not that
different so
here's the way it works um recall the
regression model looks like that
it is basically uh it is a it's an
affine
function of the feature period so here
highly interpretable for example beta 3
tells you how much x3 the third feature
figures in your prediction
v the so-called offset that's a number
which
is our prediction when the features are
all zero when x is equal to zero
okay so this is this is the regression
model
um now we can make a regression model
fit our general framework uh
all we use is the following basis
functions we use f1 is one
that's we've seen that many times so far
and then
f i of x is x i minus one so
literally the f's are uh you know
um the first one is one the next one is
x
is x one that's actually what we would
call f2 of
x is x1 and so on and so
in that case you get exactly this our
model would be
a linear combination of these basis
functions that's theta one plus theta
two x plus theta all the way up to n
plus one
x n and then we would simply write that
as x transpose theta
remember that that's a slice that means
that the second through the nth
component
they're the ones that multiply x you see
directly here
and then theta one is our offset that's
the same as v um
so what we can see is that we can fit
we can represent regression in our
general data fitting
uh in our general data fitting of
framework here
okay so regression is a special case
of linear in the parameters least
squares fitting
now it turns out we can the opposite is
true in a weird way
that suppose we have a general uh
fitting model
that's f hat is theta one f one of x
plus up to theta p e x p
um and it's extremely common to have the
first component equal to one
that's called an offset in the model or
a constant um in fact it's so common
that maybe a lot of sometimes a lot of
systems that do this stuff for you
just assume it they don't even say it
they just say there's an offset and you
actually have to call the methods with a
basically with a minus minus no offset
to actually
not have the first component be one but
okay
now we can think of this thing as a
regression model
um but not using x um actually
using this other vector here which is f
2 of x up to fp of x
and we think of those as transformed
features um
and then so the point is that our
general model
is it can be thought of as just
regression
but what we do is we think of the f's as
transform features or feature mappings
or something like that
so and that's another that's another way
to think of how we
do this kind of general fitting is we
think of thank you
in that case you'd call the x's the raw
features right
and then the f's do they trans they
transform them like for example if
you're fitting a polynomial
they would take the fourth power or the
sixth power
or something like that so that's called
uh that's called data transforming and
or feature transforming
and then you simply do regression so so
they're basically the same thing they
just have slightly different notation
systems and i should say that both
notation systems are kind of widely used
next topic is uh our is a so-called auto
regressive time series model
um now this is this is just your first
glimpse at this
uh but it's it's it's very powerful
stuff it's very cool
so i have a i have a time series z1 z2
i'm going to make these um these are
going to be scalars
for now okay so i just have a time
series it doesn't matter what it is it
could be the
well we've seen a couple of time series
right we saw world
world petroleum consumption right and
there the index
uh represents year okay it could be
hourly temperature somewhere
it could be all sorts it could be the
price of something or
uh it could be anything at all that's
all it could be an uh
some kind of um economic thing like it
could literally be the gdp
of a country or a region okay
it's a time series uh a lot of time
series i mean of course
um and so we're going to talk about now
is something called an
auto regressive model uh auto regressive
means that you're going to
make let me see what the model is the
model is this it says
uh oh we're going to use the notation z
hat uh sub t
plus one z hat t plus one is to be
interpreted as
the prediction if t is the if z if t
is now t plus one is next step
so this is actually people would say
this is the one step ahead prediction or
it's the prediction of the next value
by the way that's that can be enormously
useful in practice i mean it doesn't
doesn't take a lot of imagination to
imagine how useful this would be
if for example you could predict what
the temperature is going to be in the
next hour or something like that
right or what electricity demand is
going to be in the next hour
or what the price of something is going
to be
you know in the next one minute or one
second
right so if you can make a prediction
like that that has a lot of
value practical value okay so how do you
make this
this one step ahead prediction well
we're going to use uh
well you know you choose it you can call
it regression or you can choose a linear
parameters model
but it's going to be this it's going to
be theta 1
times zt plus theta 2 times zt minus 1
all the way up to theta m
capital m m is a mnemonic for memory
uh in the model right so for example
this would be people would refer to this
i'll show you what an ar 2. sometimes
people put
an argument in there to say what the
memory is that's where you get
capital m and that looks like this it
says z-hat
t plus 1. is equal to
theta one z t plus
theta two times z t minus one
um there it is and the model
coefficients are theta one and theta two
and it's actually beautifully
interpretable you simply say uh
i am predicting what the next value is
going to be and someone says what's your
prediction and you go well it's simple
it's theta 1 times the current value
plus theta 2 times the previous value
right so if this is daily it's like
i will predict tomorrow's value to be a
number theta one times today's value
plus a number of theta two times
yesterday's value right
and so and you can understand why this
would be called the memory because
basically it says that your prediction
has to remember the last you know
whatever approximately m
uh values of the time series okay so
that's called an
auto regressive model i think it's
called autoregressive because it's a
regression model
but we'll see that both the regressors
and the or the features x and y come
from the same thing they're z's
so that's why the auto is in there okay
now we'll choose um
actually not beta here that is a typo
we're going to choose
theta to minimize the sum of squares
of the prediction errors and that's just
going to be these so
let me point out what this is um z hat m
plus one minus z
z m that's basically this is our
prediction
of what the m plus one value of that
time series
would be based on only z1 z2 up to zm
period okay this is what it actually
was okay and so this is like an error
here that's your
that's your one step ahead prediction
error and this is the sum
of the one step ahead prediction errors
across your data set
okay so it turns out this just goes
straight
in the same form it's just it's the same
linear in the parameters model we use
y which is the outcome is simply
is literally it is the next value is
what it is
um well in the with the right indexing
and then x
i we take to be these little snippets
of the past uh the past m or m minus 1
values or something like that
right so that's that's how this works
and so this
would allow you to build up that matrix
a then you do least squares and you get
your coefficients
theta we'll look at an example
it's going to be uh it's going to the
the data is this it's the hourly
temperature at lax
the airport in la um in may 2016
and we've got 744 hours worth of data
okay on that data set the average
is 61.76 degrees fahrenheit and
i apologize to people who come from
countries that are
civilized and use you know actual actual
uh you know units but sorry
that's think of it as adding kind of a
nice cultural flavor to it okay
and the standard deviation is three
degrees fahrenheit right and so
actually this is is very nice this says
that in may 2016 if someone walked up
down the street and said what's
temperature going to be tomorrow
you could just say i don't know 61.76
degrees
and uh and the point is the rms error of
that gas is only going to be about three
degrees
right that's why it's kind of nice to
live in l.a i mean that's a little bit
cold okay but
you know it basically it says it doesn't
change it you know it doesn't change
that much
right um okay now we can compare a lot
of other predictors right
um here here's actually an extremely
sensible predictor
it's someone says what is the
temperature at lax in the next hour
and here's a completely reasonable thing
you say what is the temperature now
and they say 71 degrees and you go it'll
be 71 next hour
um that gives you an error of 1.6
you know 1.16 degrees right it's not bad
right so if you guess it
your rms air is 1.16 it's actually not
bad it means that
it means that you're usually within
about one a degree uh you might
occasionally be off by two degrees
three even but probably a lot of times
you're within one
or less right so you wouldn't be
surprised if you were only off by half a
degree
um okay um here's another
extremely interesting one z hat t plus
one you say what is the temperature
going to be
uh next in the next hour um here's one
you say well i don't know let's 2pm uh
what was the temperature yesterday
and you said that's going to be my guess
because the temperature is you know
roughly uh diurnal meaning it kind of
goes up and down
you know and at the same at 2 p.m it's
you know kind of about the same
it's cold at night warm late afternoon
so on
okay so this one
z hat t plus one equals z sub t minus
23. that gives an rms error of about two
degrees
almost two degrees so it's better than
just guessing the
mean you know just a constant right um
now if you use an ar model with with
eight
a memory of eight you get an rms error
of about one degree
under one degree right so you're
actually predicting
pretty well i mean i guess right um
i mean of course real temperature
prediction models are
way more sophisticated than just this
but nevertheless this is this is a first
cut it's very simple
uh you could write the code for it it's
about 15 lines absolutely at most
right and it's pretty cool and it's not
clear
how to you know how you would do that
and it beats these two other
simple ad hoc ones the in other words
saying
the temperature next hour will be simply
what it is now or
or what it was 24 hours ago well
reference to
one hour from now right so those are two
reasonables by the way
these kinds of these kinds of simple uh
models
these are very good things to do as a
practical matter
uh you should never jump into something
fancy like an ar model
never without doing the simple obvious
stuff first because
well for many reasons right um one is if
the people you're working with
or for have any sense at all which is
hardly a given but if they do
they and someone rushes in their office
and go oh man this is crazy i can
predict this within plus minus you know
within 15 cents it's crazy uh that they
should immediately ask
uh and it's fl you can flip the roll so
this is you somebody running into you
all excited
and uh you'd say
cool that's great i'm glad you can
predict it within 15 cents and you say
can i ask what's the standard deviation
and if the answer is like
it's 14 cents then you i don't know
get rid of the price or something like
that right um
no but the point is that you would
always do the simple stuff first uh just
if for no other reason to see how much
the fancy stuff is buying you
right and of course you have to be
emotionally
you know prepared for the fact that the
fancy stuff doesn't buy you much at all
in which case you you quietly go back
and someone says uh
and you say here's my model and you go
that's predicting a constant
but we pay you a lot we didn't we don't
pay you to come up with a constant well
i i could have said the temperature of
61.76 degrees
and at least then you can say well you
know
i tried i looked at it i analyzed it i
made some fancy models
some of the fancy models were a little
bit better but not enough better to
to justify it so that's why we're going
constant
and hopefully they'll they would
understand that
okay so let's look at an example um so
uh so here is what we do is we take this
ar8
model um and we fit it and now i'm
just going to show you for the first
five days um
so that's 120 hours i'm gonna show you
uh
both the observed value and the
prediction so
the green ones are the other are the the
actual observed values
and i think what we can conclude is that
they're they're actually integers like
when they said the temp
the temperature is like you know 55 or
61.
so okay and the blue one is
the prediction of that temperature based
on the previous eight hourly
temperatures right
and i tell you you look at it your
eyeball says
that's that's like pretty good that is
that is that is not bad
so that this is what this looks like
this is actually um
i mean these are some of the models that
come up very quickly and can be
very impressive uh in in the right in
the right settings right
where you just fit an ar model to a time
series and boy you can impress your
friends and your co-workers and things
like that